the world of Mad Max might not be as far
away as we think well okay we're not
quite there yet but a global desert is
pretty much what we're in for if we
don't change our ways water is
everything to us in fact it's almost
everything in us just go a few days
without drinking it and you'll guide
from the clothes you wear to what's on
your plate water meat it all happen but
the explosion in the world's population
has meant that the competition for the
world's limited clean water supply is
fiercer than ever before and on top of
this overconsumption pollution and the
effects of climate change have increased
the number of droughts across the world
21 of the world's 37 largest aquifers
which are crucial sources of freshwater
are being drained faster than the water
is being replaced and the situation is
getting worse by 2025 almost two billion
people will be living in areas suffering
from water scarcity these changes mean
the water Wars of the future will
eclipse those of the past in scale and
importance but there are also the
optimists they say this struggle for
water will encourage international
cooperation and innovative new
technologies to deal with the problem
there's no shortage of inventions that
can make us hopeful so save those tears
the apocalypse might just need to wait a
little while longer
want more on water check out our running
dry playlist